this is technically your first lead role
yes since Kelly and Jeff from - Kelly -
Justin no yeah that was the worst thing
ever
I was contractually obligated to do that
one this one I volunteered I've always
believed the big world is real I know
I'll find the perfect kid for me but I'm
starting to wonder with no evidence no
proof what if it's not true find your
own truth you're this character though
is something special and little girls
but although kids can walk away and feel
like they've learned something yeah made
a movie don't like I watched the movie
they're not with adults as well as our
kids which we it was kind of were they
gonna pay attention the whole time you
know and they did so I was like success
cuz they're three and four so um but the
adults do like you just watch it and
it's just a great message I feel like
right now like everything is very
divisive very serious very like it's
like a nice form of escapism and a
reminder of like the great part of parts
about humanity do your kids get that
that's you my son my son just turned 3
yesterday he doesn't quiet
he kind of does but because we told him
but you know our old or too obvious to
do an art my daughter I pretty much
crushed her her dreams of like she
didn't realize I didn't really realize
what I was doing and I was explaining to
her she was confused and I said was my
voice like we you know like hell Elson
on I like there's a person that plays
I'll say and I didn't get what I was
doing I didn't get it I did it I did it
and I felt hurt but she's very clever
she would have figured it out after
finding out that I'm the she would have
figured it out but that means I'm
justifying it to make myself so it hurts
her I saw her little face and I just saw
the wheels spinning and I was like oh no
but isn't it exciting that you could
meet the real girl
please like let's flip this into a
positive oh my god it was so sad how
much fun was it making this and getting
in the booth every day and just being
you and no hair no makeup and over yeah
well I was in hair and makeup a lot just
because I knew they'd use some of the
film now they use everything for
everything you know what I'm saying so
more so I didn't I think there was one
time that I came in like a hat and no
makeup but um but it was it was fun
though because none of the other
characters had done their voices yet so
I literally fed off of Kellie aspirated
the director like so I we just we just
went back and forth the whole time and
he really I mean I trusted him a lot
because I'd never done anything like
this and you know had to be very
vulnerable and willing to well I'm
willing to look like an idiot all the
time so that wasn't a far stretch but
but i but I you know really just had to
lean in and trust him and where the
movie was going cuz I didn't know all
that he knew can we talk about the ACMs
for a second yeah did somebody think you
were a seat-filler somebody thought I
was a seat-filler
what it was amazing so because I had
Chanel Shepherd who won season 15 in the
voice and I had her walk the carpet
umekes you were making she's making a
record and and she's country music and
so and literally we had run into
everyone I wanted to make it a magical
night for him we ran into everyone
talked to Brandon Carl on Casey and
Carrie area Dirk's like Luke she got to
see everyone I thought what I was like
all these people like yes I'm having
like and then like you know the universe
God just steps her and I'd like to
Humble you like I've said no to much but
Midland comes in a band comes in and uh
and this guy goes yeah man we're getting
you to move we need to sit flush the
mood for the bands to come or the talent
for the talent to come in and I was like
oh and then you feel like a stuffed
sausage you're like I'm backed in
[Music]